my name is riotta and welcome to haifa
last wednesday was my birthday and hell
haha hold on hold on you don't have to
write happy birthday anymore I already
got so much so many comments so many
things that you bro is dead and I wasn't
really online that day that much so I
didn't get a chance to really fully
acknowledge the the things that you did
it was like a poem that was on the front
page of bacon art there was so many fan
arts that you bros made and sent send me
a bunch of males and stuff really hide
in my day and it really made me even
happier to have you bros more or less
with me on my birthday
so thank Thank You Brad but we're gonna
open man you're gonna [ __ ] enjoy it
I'll be looking at you Jerry so when his
name is Jerry is mind blown right now we
have an awesome adventure time fan art
is that Jake is Stefano there we yeah
well first of all happy birthday thank
you absolutely love you in your videos
every day I watched as many videos as I
can and you never failed to put a smile
on my face I'm become happy if you bros
happy so thank you for this awesome fan
oh there is something more than laughter
inside a letter
let's flexion
hey thank you for the happy birthday
pads oh right
someone tell me face creams thank you
but I'm actually really scared of face
creams oh it's a tiny phobia of mine I
think they're the most disgusting thing
I do not want creams on me whatsoever
just me I think it's just me but hey a
big package that's for Marcia come Tampa
I was so happy
let's look at it together actually I
can't see it yet Hey
barrels where's my period yeah well it's
awesome I love it I'm paying you a lot
Oh doc really
it's from an Italian person
probablemente do you like my Italian
this is that's not do you like Google
visit our web the Italian oh there's a
letter inside the letter I am so
confused by death by Italian Jackson
stop what is Oh
ah you know what we put you here will
put Slendy inside him good come on don't
[ __ ] with me as a breakfast on the
letter that's always a good thing
Finn if I I'm a big fan of you and you
just won't say you're awesome and keep
doing your videos because they are the
best and me also I love it
Friday Carla I'm buff this [ __ ] they're
eating my hat why would you eat my hand
seriously yeah I'm pumped and awesome
let's put a net ye oh ye from Jamie be
terrify you awesome I love all your
video Thank You Brad ruff alright so I
don't know why but I now have a luggage
tag and again I don't know why but now I
have a paper airplane Debbie Allen's own
puppy air Thank You Brad and I don't
know why I just basically don't know why
but I have an inflatable dinosaur I'm
jelly are you right now from a scale
from 1-10 thank you yeah there's always
this one but one thing that I was like
what the [ __ ]
my buddy
hahaha I'm gonna oh my god that
handwriting is guard yet look at here we
got mrs. chick okay half the back I
PewDiePie and happy birthday we really
like watching your videos they're so
funny but we get scared every time you
shop out well that's barrels fault not
mine Joana and Francesca they are really
awesome drawers look at that sofa and
rattle and
I had pretty I'm not pretty
Iraq oh this one says formats and this
one says for kid by yeah yeah like ah
that's not the game I'll clean this I
promise
battle killing kit [ __ ] a check what
what is this a suffocation inside okay
okay
I'm supposed to stuff okay fire is he
wrote that it's not real so don't worry
it's not real thing ever oh my god uh
that's the fire
I'm glad Nate said that he wasn't real
cuz I would have thought that was real
on the way
toilet seat why would I kill someone
with the toilet actually I did that in
condemn that I think about it you know I
I really like this idea alright final
chilling kid I think I'll save this for
like a spot and if I ever feel angry
I'll just pop out my battle kit destroy
it and what else oh no way
also I love it look at that it's so cool
Thank You Russ I even got like my
headphones and everything that's cool
thank you bruh oh your brother's look
huh I am deserve ear rot all right
breast
thanks thank you really thank you for
all the gift item that's so sweet of you
it really means a lot to me
really that so thank you to put up your
fists and let's profit are you ready
I'm not I'm not gonna jinx it I'm sorry
my life hi hi are you still had all
right all right you ready for this orna
dust right bro for your thermo activate